From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I want to play something for you today. And before I do, I want to get in front of something. The story is about Guantánamo. And I think lots of us hear "Guantánamo" at this point, and we think, ugh, it's heavy, and it's complicated. And is it really still going on? And don't I really know everything I already need to know about Guantánamo?
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我想为您播放一段内容。在开始之前，我想先说明一下。这个故事关于关塔那摩。我想我们很多人听到“关塔那摩”这个词时，会觉得，哎，太沉重了，太复杂了。它真的还在运作吗？关于关塔那摩，难道我还需要知道更多吗？
Maybe you've heard our co-workers Sarah Koenig and Dana Chivvis over at Serial. They've been rolling out season four of Serial, and it's all about Guantánamo. And the premise of the show is, enough time has passed that all these people who were there in its heyday can finally talk publicly about what really happened-- what it was like to work there, what it was like to be imprisoned there.
也许您听过我们在《Serial》节目的同事萨拉·凯尼格和达娜·奇维斯。她们正在推出《Serial》第四季，全季内容都围绕关塔那摩展开。节目的前提是，距离它鼎盛时期已经过去足够长的时间，当初身处其中的人们终于可以公开谈论那里到底发生了什么——在那里工作是什么感觉，被关押在那里又是什么感觉。
And you hear all these ordinary people who were thrown into this extraordinary situation where there were guards and interrogators and commanders and detainees and this invented offshore prison with its own weird, brand-new rules. And you finally get a very clear sense of what it was like in there.
您可以听到所有这些普通人被卷入这种非凡境遇中的故事，那里有狱警、审讯官、指挥官、被拘留者，还有一个有着奇特、全新规则的虚构离岸监狱。通过这些，您终于能清晰地感受到那里面究竟是什么样子。
But there are two episodes that they made that are about stuff that's just happened down there in the last couple of years, and about stuff that is going to happen, that's going to be in the news. And honestly, what I heard these two episodes, I thought-- I know this sounds kind of grand. I thought, really, every American should hear these. They're the kind of stories that, when you hear them, it totally changes how you understand the news after that. And they're also just amazing stories.
但她们制作的两集节目讲述的是过去几年在那儿发生的事情，以及即将发生、即将登上新闻的事情。说实话，听完这两集，我觉得——我知道这听起来有点夸张——但我认为，真的，每个美国人都应该听听。这类故事一旦听过，就会彻底改变您对之后新闻的理解。而且，它们本身也是非常惊人的故事。
And so what we're going to do this week and next, we're going to do something we've never done. We're going to run these two episodes from Serial, two full episodes on our show. And so, right now, today, here is the first of those two episodes. Dana Chivvis, co-host this season of Serial, and she does this one.
所以，本周和下周，我们将做一件从未做过的事情。我们将在节目中播放《Serial》的这两集内容，两集完整的节目。所以，此时此刻，今天，先为您带来这两集中的第一集。达娜·奇维斯，本季《Serial》的联合主持人，这一集由她制作。
Majid Khan was 16 when his family moved to Baltimore from Pakistan. He went to Owings Mills High School, smoked weed, worked at his dad's gas station, and thought about becoming a DJ under the stage name "Bob Day-si." He listened to Eminem and watched Law and Order and paid attention in Ms. Sanford's social studies class, where he learned about checks and balances and due process. So when Majid Khan found himself locked away in a cold, dark cell at a black site in 2003, he told the CIA he wanted to see a lawyer.
马吉德·汗16岁时，随家人从巴基斯坦搬到了巴尔的摩。他上了欧文斯米尔斯高中，抽过大麻，在他爸爸的加油站打工，还想过以“Bob Day-si”的艺名成为一名DJ。他听埃米纳姆的歌，看《法律与秩序》，在桑福德女士的社会研究课上很专心，学会了权力制衡和正当程序。所以，当马吉德·汗2003年发现自己被锁在黑狱一间阴冷黑暗的牢房里时，他告诉中情局他想见律师。
CIA is just shocked. It's like, what do you thinking, who you are and where you are? It's like, you're talking about rights? Son, the gloves came off a long time ago. That's what they tell me.
中情局感到非常震惊。他们像是说，你在想什么？你知道你是谁，你在哪里吗？你在谈论权利？孩子，我们早就不用温和手段了。他们就是这么对我说的。
I was like, no. No, I still believe in due process. I still believe in due process. Right or wrong, whatever I did, I believe in due process.
我说，不。不，我仍然相信正当程序。我仍然相信正当程序。无论对错，无论我做了什么，我依然相信正当程序。
What he did-- instead of becoming a DJ, Majid joined al-Qaeda, reported directly to Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the admitted mastermind of 9/11. Naturally, the CIA had questions for him, but the way they asked those questions, they tortured him at black sites for years. And when they were done, they sent him to Guantánamo in shackles and a diaper.
他做了什么呢——马吉德没有成为DJ，而是加入了基地组织，直接向9/11事件公认的策划者哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德汇报。理所当然，中情局对他有疑问，但他们提问的方式是，在黑狱中对他进行了多年的酷刑。当他们折磨够了，就给他戴上镣铐，包上尿布，把他送到了关塔那摩。
Majid did bad things. He joined al-Qaeda, wore a suicide vest, tried to kill the Pakistani president. He came up with plots targeting the American government to blow up gas stations and poison the water supply near military installations, to sell poisoned medication in the United States. He delivered $50,000 to another terrorist, money the United States says was used to fund a suicide bombing that killed 11 people and injured at least 81 others.
马吉德确实做了坏事。他加入了基地组织，穿过自杀式炸弹背心，试图暗杀巴基斯坦总统。他策划了针对美国政府的阴谋，企图炸毁加油站、毒害军事设施附近的供水系统，并在美国销售有毒药品。他交给另一名恐怖分子5万美元，美国称这笔钱被用于资助一起自杀式爆炸袭击，造成11人死亡，至少81人受伤。
And then we did bad things back to Majid. We disappeared him for three years, locked him away for 20, tortured him.
然后我们以牙还牙，对马吉德做了坏事。我们让他“被消失”了三年，将他关押了20年，对他施以酷刑。
This story is about two ledgers-- on one side, what Majid did to us; on the other, what we did to Majid. How do you weigh those against each other? In the historical accounting to come, which is worse? Majid's case is the first time at Guantánamo those ledgers are compared, and someone has to render a verdict.
这个故事关乎两笔账——一方面，马吉德对我们做了什么；另一方面，我们对马吉德做了什么。你如何衡量这两者？在未来的历史清算中，哪一个更糟糕？马吉德的案子是关塔那摩第一次对这些账目进行对比，而且必须有人做出判决。
Majid's story starts with his radicalization. Unlike so many former Guantánamo detainees, there's clear public evidence that he was in al-Qaeda. He admits it. So this is a rare chance to hear how someone made the leap from self-described normal American teenager to self-described terrorist. It's actually quite simple, to hear Majid tell it.
马吉德的故事始于他的激进化。与许多前关塔那摩被拘留者不同，有明确的公开证据表明他确实在基地组织。他自己也承认了。所以，这是一个难得的机会，去听听一个人如何从一个自称正常的美国青少年跨越到自称恐怖分子的过程。听马吉德讲来，其实很简单。
The reason I joined al-Qaeda was the Palestine issue.
我加入基地组织的原因是巴勒斯坦问题。
It begins with Palestine.
一切始于巴勒斯坦。
I had nothing against America. I didn't have it then. I don't have it now. It's your fucking stupid foreign policy that your leaders make-- right?-- that I criticized.
我并不反对美国。当时没有。现在也没有。我批评的是你们领导人制定的那些该死的愚蠢的外交政策，对吧？
Some people might remember President George Bush explaining September 11th, saying that al-Qaeda attacked us because they hate our freedoms, our liberty. Actually, what al-Qaeda really hated was our support for Israel, that we had troops in Kuwait and Saudi Arabia, that we had invaded Iraq the first time in 1991.
有些人可能还记得乔治·布什总统解释9/11事件时说，基地组织袭击我们是因为他们憎恨我们的自由和民主。实际上，基地组织真正憎恨的是我们对以色列的支持，我们在科威特和沙特阿拉伯驻军，以及我们在1991年第一次入侵伊拉克。
When I visited Majid last year in Belize, where he now lives with his wife and two kids in a bright-green cottage not far from the sea, it was November 2023, just weeks since the October 7 terrorist attacks on Israel and the start of the relentless bombing of Gaza in return. He had been watching a lot of cable news coverage of the war and TikTok videos.
去年，我在伯利兹拜访了马吉德。他现在和妻子及两个孩子住在离海不远的一栋亮绿色小屋里。那是2023年11月，距离10月7日针对以色列的恐怖袭击以及随后对加沙发动的无情轰炸仅过去几周。他一直在看关于战争的有线电视新闻报道和TikTok视频。
Like so many people, Muslims and non-Muslims alike, he was fired up about the atrocities there, the same kinds of atrocities that had spurred him to join al-Qaeda two decades ago. What he was seeing was Americans making the same mistakes all over again, supporting Israel.
像许多人一样，无论是穆斯林还是非穆斯林，他都对那里的暴行感到愤怒，这与二十年前促使他加入基地组织的暴行是一样的。他所看到的是美国人再次犯下同样的错误，继续支持以色列。
You guys are so powerful, so smart, and you guys so dumbass at the same time. No offense. [LAUGHS] I mean, I'm not an American, OK, by citizenship. But you guys amaze me every single time.
你们这些人既强大又聪明，但同时又蠢得要命。别介意。[笑] 我的意思是我不是美国公民。但你们每次都让我感到惊讶。
What's the dumbass part?
哪部分蠢得要命？
Not getting the basics! And I'm thinking, there could be another Majid Khan somewhere right now. Now, imagine that, back then, we didn't have YouTube, we didn't have Instagram.
不了解基本常识！我在想，现在某个地方可能还有另一个马吉德·汗。想象一下，当年我们没有YouTube，没有Instagram。
And I'm thinking, what are they thinking, these kids? And they're so stupid kids. So they could be easily misled. And I'm thinking, how many Majid Khan out there right now that will become like me?
我在想，这些孩子在想什么？他们还是太蠢了。所以他们很容易被误导。我在想，现在外面还有多少个马吉德·汗会变得像我一样？
What led Majid to extremism was a confluence of events. Growing up, he wasn't very religious. He and his parents, his seven siblings, they didn't pray regularly. He says his mother was anti-religion. When he grew a beard, she made him shave it off.
导致马吉德走向极端主义的是一系列事件的汇合。在成长过程中，他并不是很虔诚。他和父母及七个兄弟姐妹并不常祈祷。他说他的母亲是反宗教的。当他留胡子时，她强迫他剃掉。
But in his late teenage years after his family moved to Baltimore, he struggled with his identity. He wanted to fit into American high school life, to be cool, but he wasn't sure that being cool was very Majid. He felt guilty that he didn't pray, that he was a bad Muslim.
但在青少年时期后期，全家搬到巴尔的摩后，他在身份认同上挣扎。他想融入美国的高中生活，想变得很酷，但他不确定变得“酷”是否还是那个马吉德。他对自己不祈祷、自己是个坏穆斯林感到内疚。
He started learning more about Islam from a group of proselytizers called the Tablighi Jamaat, who would visit him at work and at the mosque.
他开始从一个叫“Tablighi Jamaat”的传教团体那里更多地了解伊斯兰教，他们会去他工作的地方和清真寺拜访他。
And then, when he was 21, Majid's mother died suddenly. She was the most important person in his life, the center of their family. He says he was devastated.
21岁那年，马吉德的母亲突然去世。她是马吉德生命中最重要的人，是家庭的核心。他说他心碎欲绝。
He started asking the big questions about life and death. He felt like he had sinned up until that point, had wasted his life. He decided to devote himself to Islam. No more partying, no more smoking weed.
他开始思考关于生命和死亡的重大问题。他觉得到那时为止自己犯了太多罪，浪费了生命。他决定投身于伊斯兰教。不再聚会，不再抽大麻。
And it was at this point that he started getting more political. At the mosque, they talked about Palestine. The world seemed black and white to him.
正是在这个时候，他变得更加政治化了。在清真寺里，他们谈论巴勒斯坦。世界在他眼中变成了非黑即白。
At some point in my life, I had to choose a path. Do you want to be siding with the oppressed or oppressor? I chose to be siding with the oppressed.
在我生命中的某个时刻，我必须选择一条道路。你是想站在被压迫者一边，还是站在压迫者一边？我选择站在被压迫者一边。
Nine months after his mother's death, he went to Pakistan for a bunch of family weddings. His family wanted to arrange a marriage for him, too. And secretly, he also had a fantasy of joining the jihad, maybe training at the camps in Afghanistan.
母亲去世九个月后，他前往巴基斯坦参加一连串的家庭婚礼。家人也想为他安排婚事。而暗地里，他还有一个参加圣战的幻想，也许能在阿富汗的营地里接受训练。
Growing up in Pakistan, Majid heard a lot about the mujahideen, how honorable they were, how brave-- like the Navy SEALs in the United States, he says. He didn't particularly care which jihadi group he joined. There were a bunch of them.
在巴基斯坦长大，马吉德听过很多关于圣战者的故事，他们是多么光荣，多么勇敢——他说，就像美国的“海豹突击队”。他并不特别在意加入哪个圣战组织，那里有很多个。
I'll be honest with you, I didn't go to Pakistan to join al-Qaeda. They came to me. Out of billion people, billions of Muslims, I happen to have cousin and an uncle that are al-Qaeda leaders.
老实说，我去巴基斯坦不是为了加入基地组织。是他们找上我。在十亿、几十亿穆斯林中，偏偏我的表亲和叔叔就是基地组织的领导人。
It was January 2002, four months after 9/11. bin Laden had denied responsibility for the attacks, though the American government had quickly concluded al-Qaeda was behind them. Majid didn't believe it.
那时是2002年1月，9/11事件四个月后。本·拉登否认了对袭击负责，尽管美国政府很快得出结论，认为幕后黑手是基地组织。马吉德不信。
And then part of me is like, come on, Muslim could do it? And I'm into conspiracy theories. I was like, no way.
我心里的一部分会想，算了吧，穆斯林能干出这种事？我喜欢阴谋论。我觉得根本不可能。
I told my uncle and my cousin, like, dude, I knew the Jews were behind it. I saw it on the internet. I saw CIA were behind it. They were laughing at me.
我跟叔叔和表亲说，伙计，我知道是犹太人干的。我在网上看到了。我看到是中情局干的。他们都在嘲笑我。
His uncle and cousin convinced him. No, it wasn't an inside job. The Jews didn't do it. It was al-Qaeda. It was us. But instead of being horrified by this information, Majid joined them.
他的叔叔和表亲说服了他。不，这不是内鬼干的。不是犹太人干的。是基地组织。是我们干的。但马吉德听到这个消息后并没有感到恐惧，反而加入了他们。
I was already pissed off about the Palestine thing. Somehow, though, what I understood that happened-- I got to be careful what I'm about to say. It could be misconstrued. Almost, in my mind-- and I wasn't alone. There was some Islamic community members that I was with that they did not appreciate it, but almost had like they had it coming.
我对巴勒斯坦的事已经很火大了。但不知怎么的，关于所发生的事——我得小心说话。这可能会被误解。在我心目中——我并不孤单。我身边的某些伊斯兰社区成员并不赞赏这种行为，但几乎觉得那是罪有应得。
Like the United States had it coming?
就像美国罪有应得？
The United States had it coming because of what they were doing in Palestine and the Islamic countries.
美国罪有应得，因为他们对巴勒斯坦和伊斯兰国家所做的一切。
And that's how you felt about it?
你当时就是这么觉得的？
And that's how I felt about it at the time. I didn't like it, but it just-- I was so mad, what was happening in Palestine. And it's just hard to explain that-- I've never killed before. I have never seen suffering before. But somehow that what was happening in Palestine affected me so much, that somehow I was OK to say, well, they had it coming.
当时我就是那么想的。我不喜欢那样，但就是——我太愤怒了，因为巴勒斯坦发生的事情。这很难解释——我以前从未杀过人。我以前从未见过受苦。但不知怎么的，巴勒斯坦发生的事情对我影响太大了，以至于我竟然能说，好吧，他们是罪有应得。
Just like, I was just watching Fox News yesterday, and everybody in Fox News-- well, if the Palestinian didn't like it, well, they had it coming. They were the one who selected Hamas to be operating in Gaza. Same thing. I was in that mindset.
就像我昨天看福克斯新闻一样，福克斯新闻上的每个人都说——好吧，如果巴勒斯坦人不满意，那是他们罪有应得。是他们自己选择了哈马斯在加沙活动。是一样的。我当时就是这种心态。
I must tell you, I know I'm being honest with you, but I may come across callous. But this is a brutal truth. So please bear with me, and try to understand.
我必须告诉您，我知道我对自己很诚实，但这听起来可能很冷酷。但这是残酷的真相。所以请忍受我，并试着理解。
I am not trying to offend you guys. I know you guys-- an American and patriotic American. I hope you are, and you should be. And you should get a little irritated by these statements, and you should be. But I am just telling you, I can't sugarcoat my statement so that I can please you.
我不是想冒犯你们。我知道你们——你们是美国人，爱国的美国人。我希望你们是，你们也应该如此。你们理应对这些陈述感到不满，你们确实应该。但我只是在告诉您，我不能为了取悦您而粉饰我的话。
Let me be clear. Majid says he has long since rejected extremism. He left al-Qaeda while he was still locked up at Guantánamo. He says he doesn't think 9/11 was righteous or good or justified, but he does understand the twisted logic behind al-Qaeda's attacks because at the age of 21, he believed in that logic himself. He has a unique perspective of a person who has lived fully immersed in both the culture of the United States and the culture of al-Qaeda. He can explain both worlds with fluency.
让我澄清一下。马吉德说他早已拒绝了极端主义。他在被关押在关塔那摩期间就离开了基地组织。他说他不认为9/11事件是正义的、好的或合理的，但他确实理解基地组织袭击背后的扭曲逻辑，因为他在21岁时自己就相信那种逻辑。他拥有一个独特视角，即一个完全沉浸在美国文化和基地组织文化中的人。他能流利地解释这两个世界。
Once he was in al-Qaeda, arguably, the worst thing Majid did is what Majid did not do. He did not assassinate Pakistani president Pervez Musharraf in a suicide attack, but he tried to. When he joined al-Qaeda, Majid volunteered to be a suicide bomber.
加入基地组织后，马吉德做过的最糟糕的事情可以说就是他“没做”成的事情。他没有通过自杀式袭击刺杀巴基斯坦总统佩尔韦兹·穆沙拉夫，但他尝试过。加入基地组织时，马吉德主动请缨当自杀式炸弹袭击者。
I had shown my willingness to my cousin and told my uncle that, hey, by the way, if there's an opportunity, let me know.
我向我的表亲表达了我的意愿，并告诉我的叔叔说，嘿，顺便说一下，如果有机会，告诉我。
Did you say that with any kind of thought, or did you just sort of, like, offer yourself up without really thinking it through?
你说这话时是深思熟虑的，还是只是随口一说，没有经过认真考虑？
No, I mean, I was sincere. I truly believed that this is the way to go to heaven. Beyond-- how sure are you it's night right now?
不，我是认真的。我真心相信这就是去天堂的路。除了——你现在有多确定现在是晚上？
It's very dark out, yeah.
外面很黑，是的。
Yeah, I was that sure. That's the way to go.
是的，我当时就是那么确定。那就是去天堂的路。
And you wanted that why?
你为什么想要那样？
Who doesn't want to go to heaven?
谁不想去天堂呢？
Well, I mean, you were 20. Like, you had so much of your life ahead of you.
我的意思是，你才20岁。你的人生还有那么长的路要走。
Yeah, the test is over. See? This life is test. The test is over.
是的，考试结束了。看，这一生就是场考试。考试结束了。
Majid's family had arranged a marriage for him to Rabia. They're still married today. He says their wedding was the happiest day of his life. But while they were on their honeymoon, KSM, Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, called Majid's cousin. He had a job for Majid to do back in Karachi.
马吉德的家人为他安排了与拉比亚的婚姻。他们至今仍是夫妻。他说他们的婚礼是他一生中最幸福的一天。但当他们在度蜜月时，KSM（哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德）给马吉德的表亲打了电话。他在卡拉奇有个活儿要马吉德做。
The job was a suicide mission. Majid would wear an explosive vest to a mosque where the Pakistani president, Musharraf, was expected to attend Friday prayers. At a safe house in Karachi, Majid tried on the vest.
那是个自杀任务。马吉德要穿上炸弹背心去一个清真寺，巴基斯坦总统穆沙拉夫预计会去那里参加周五祈祷。在卡拉奇的一个安全屋里，马吉德试穿了背心。
KSM told me how to wear it and how to reach out to him, how close to get to blow him up, and basic training like where to sit when he reaches. Try to get as close as possible.
KSM告诉我要怎么穿，怎么接近他，离多近引爆，还有一些基本训练，比如到了之后坐在哪儿。试着尽可能靠近。
The idea was, if you can just hug him, it'll be perfect. And he told me like, just remember that the idea was to do less damage to the people. If you can get close and shake hands and just hug him and then press the button, perfect.
想法是，如果你能抱住他，那就完美了。他告诉我就记住，主旨是对其他人造成的伤害越小越好。如果你能靠近，握握手，抱住他，然后按下按钮，那就完美了。
He says he did ask KSM, what about all the civilians who would be killed?
他说他确实问过KSM，那会被杀死的平民怎么办？
Yeah, I did ask him. I did ask him. I said, what about the civilians? He justified there was some hadith was done where the Prophet was at war. And in nighttime, there was unintentionally some civilian were killed. Basically, in American language, it was collateral damage. We don't want to do it, unless we have no option.
是的，我确实问过。我问他，那些平民呢？他辩解说，先知在战争时曾有圣训。在夜间，会有无意间杀死平民的情况。基本上，用美国话来说，就是“附带损害”。我们不想这样做，除非别无选择。
But somehow, when you are in this cycle that I was in, it's like being in a tornado, you know? There's not much time. You're not thinking. You're not saying, oh, by the way, let's just think about this, right?
但不知怎么的，当你处于我当时那种循环中时，就像在龙卷风里，你知道吗？没多少时间。你不会思考。你不会说，哦，顺便问一下，让我们思考一下这件事，对吧？
If I could go back and change it, I would. I wish I could go back and tell myself, calm down, cowboy. You know? Think what you're doing. There's the consequences of your actions. Didn't think about my family and none of that stuff.
如果能回去改变它，我会的。我希望我能回去告诉自己，冷静点，牛仔。你知道吗？想想你在做什么。你的行为是有后果的。我那时根本没考虑我的家人或其他任何事情。
On that Friday morning, KSM drove Majid to the mosque in a red Suzuki. He sat through all of Friday prayers in the suicide vest. He told me he was calm. He even fell asleep at one point because he was a little bored. He just wanted to get on with it. But Musharraf never showed up.
那个周五早上，KSM开着一辆红色铃木载马吉德去了清真寺。他穿着自杀背心参加了整个周五祈祷。他告诉我他当时很冷静。他甚至一度睡着了，因为觉得有点无聊。他只想赶紧结束。但穆沙拉夫根本没露面。
After the failed suicide attack, Majid continued plotting with KSM to blow up gas stations, to import explosives into the United States. They talked about Majid becoming a sleeper agent back home. He returned to Baltimore for a few months, where he was supposed to recruit others to join al-Qaeda. But once he was home, his new path and his new identity, jihadi Majid, were not so clear.
自杀式袭击失败后，马吉德继续与KSM密谋炸毁加油站，向美国进口炸药。他们谈论马吉德成为潜伏在家的间谍。他回到巴尔的摩呆了几个月，本应招募其他人加入基地组织。但一旦回到家，他的新道路和新身份——“圣战者马吉德”——就不那么清晰了。
When I was in the States, it's fascinating. I was like, OK, life is not that bad. It's like I'm living an American life. And then I talked to my cousin and uncle, and then they said, look, your po, your heart has been poisoned again with the West and the love of West. So come back to us. We will purify your heart.
当我在美国时，这很迷人。我想，好吧，生活也不错。就像在过美国生活。然后我跟表亲和叔叔谈话，他们说，看，你的心又被西方和对西方的爱所毒害了。回来吧，回到我们身边。我们会净化你的心。
I just-- identity crisis-- I don't know, whatever you want to call it. I loved living in America in a sense that my family and friends were there. That's great. But part of me said, look, they're right, too. I want to be part of Mujahideen as well.
我只是——身份危机——我不知道，随便你怎么叫它。我喜欢在美国生活，因为我的家人和朋友都在那里。那很好。但内心的一部分说，看，他们说得也对。我也想成为圣战者的一员。
According to the United States government and to Majid himself, he never directly physically injured anyone. The plots he and KSM dreamt up were abandoned. He never wore a suicide vest again.
根据美国政府和马吉德本人的说法，他从未直接造成任何人身体上的伤害。他和KSM构想的阴谋都被放弃了。他再也没穿过自杀背心。
The most clear of his crimes, with the gravest consequences, according to the US government, was delivering the $50,000 to another terrorist group, which prosecutors say was used to fund the JW Marriott Hotel bombing in Jakarta. Majid says he didn't know about the bomb plot or what the money would be used for. He was just told to deliver it. But, of course, the person who asked him to deliver it was Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the architect of 9/11.
根据美国政府的说法，他所犯下的罪行中后果最严重的，是向另一个恐怖组织运送了5万美元。检察官称这笔钱被用于资助雅加达JW万豪酒店的爆炸案。马吉德说他并不知道炸弹阴谋，也不知道钱会被用来干什么。他只是被告知送过去。但当然，让他送钱的人是9/11的设计师哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德。
By the time the bombing happened, Majid was already in American custody. Early one morning in March 2003, he'd been woken up by his brother. He was staying at his apartment in Karachi. They heard shouting and banging on the door. It was Pakistani intelligence. "Are you Bob Day-si?" they shouted at him. He'd used his DJ name on a Hotmail account.
爆炸发生时，马吉德已经在美国的监护下。2003年3月的一个清晨，他被兄弟叫醒。他当时住在卡拉奇的一间公寓里。他们听到外面有大喊声和敲门声。是巴基斯坦情报局的人。“你是Bob Day-si吗？”他们对他大喊。他曾在一个Hotmail账户上用过这个DJ名字。
They took him into custody, interrogated him, and beat him. There were FBI agents and some other unidentified Americans there, too. And then, after months of this, he was turned over to the CIA. This is where the story of what Majid did ends and the story of what we did to Majid begins.
他们逮捕了他，审讯他，并殴打他。那里还有联邦调查局特工和一些身份不明的美国人。几个月后，他被移交给中情局。这就是马吉德“所作所为”的故事结束，我们对马吉德“所作所为”的故事开始的地方。
The details of Majid's time in the CIA black sites have been covered in the news and in the Senate's report on the CIA's rendition, detention, and interrogation program, the so-called "torture report." The torture he endured was intense and brutal, which is why I was surprised to learn that he came away from it all with a respect for the CIA, a kind of opponent's respect.
关于马吉德在中情局黑狱这段时间的细节，已经在新闻和参议院关于中情局引渡、拘留和审讯计划的报告（所谓的“酷刑报告”）中被披露。他所承受的酷刑是剧烈且残酷的，这就是为什么我很惊讶地发现，他在经历这一切后，竟然对中情局产生了一种尊重，一种对手之间的尊重。
It was one of the first things he told me when I arrived in Belize. We were sitting on a couch in his living room. His daughter had just made us some tea. Two fans were blowing the sticky Caribbean air around, and he just launched into it, how he appreciated the candor of the CIA.
这是我抵达伯利兹时他告诉我的第一件事。我们坐在他客厅的沙发上。他女儿刚给我们泡了茶。两台风扇吹着潮湿的加勒比空气，他就直接聊开了，谈到他如何欣赏中情局的坦诚。
We had a very frank conversation. I mean, and they won't BS with us. I mean, they were so honest with us. Like, dude, I'm going to torture you tomorrow. They're going to torture me tomorrow. [CHUCKLES] And when they were done torturing me tomorrow, after one week, they're done. OK, we're not going to torture you anymore. I mean, they were very frank, very straightforward.
我们进行了非常坦率的谈话。我的意思是，他们不会跟我们玩虚的。他们对我们太诚实了。就像，伙计，明天我要折磨你了。他们明天要折磨我。[笑] 当他们折磨完之后，过了一周，他们就停了。好吧，我们不再折磨你了。我的意思是，他们非常坦率，非常直截了当。
He said all the prisoners with him in Camp 7-- that's the secret prison at Guantánamo, where he was eventually held, along with KSM and other men who had been tortured by the CIA-- all the prisoners in Camp 7 felt that way.
他说所有和他一起在第7营——即关塔那摩的秘密监狱，他最终被关在那里，和KSM以及其他被中情局折磨过的人一起——的所有囚犯都是这种感觉。
I mean, I've talked to KSM. I've talked to all the brothers in Camp 7. We actually had a lot of respect for CIA.
我的意思是，我跟KSM谈过。我跟第7营的所有兄弟们谈过。我们其实对中情局有很多尊重。
We understood why they're torturing us. We understood they want intelligence. It's part of the business. It comes with the job. And our job is to hold intelligence as much as possible, as much as bearable. And we had a mutual respect for that.
我们理解他们为什么要折磨我们。我们理解他们想要情报。这是生意的一部分。这是工作带来的。而我们的工作是在承受范围之内尽可能地保守情报。我们对此有一种相互尊重。
It's not that Majid was OK with being tortured, of course. The CIA did horrifying things to him at the black sites.
当然，马吉德并不是乐意遭受酷刑。中情局在黑狱里对他做了令人毛骨悚然的事情。
He was held underwater, hanged, force fed, short shackled. He was left naked in the cold, in the dark, with music blasting. He didn't see the sun for two years, except in the brief moments when he was transported between buildings. He had barely any human contact, just his guards, his interrogators, and his torturers.
他被按在水下、吊起来、强迫进食、戴短镣铐。他赤身裸体地被关在寒冷、黑暗中，伴随着震耳欲聋的音乐。他有两年时间没见过太阳，除了在建筑物之间被转运的短暂瞬间。他几乎没有任何人际接触，只有狱警、审讯官和折磨他的人。
One of the reasons why Majid wanted me to understand his respect for the CIA was so I would understand how he felt about his treatment at Guantánamo to contrast it. Because for Majid, his time in Camp 7 was worse.
马吉德想让我理解他对中情局的这种尊重的原因之一，是想让我理解他对关塔那摩待遇的感受，与之形成对比。因为对马吉德来说，他在第7营的那段时间更糟糕。
He wasn't being interrogated anymore. Sometimes the FBI would pay him a visit, ask him some questions. But that's it. So the cruelty at Guantánamo had no purpose.
他不再被审讯了。有时联邦调查局会去探望他，问一些问题。但也就仅此而已。所以关塔那摩的残酷是毫无目的的。
CIA torture was like surgical. OK, for a few hours, a few months or whatever, they're trying to-- there's a reason behind it. They're doing it. I get it, why they're doing it.
中情局的酷刑就像手术一样。好吧，几个小时，几个月，或者无论多久，他们试图——背后是有原因的。他们这么做，我明白为什么。
But there was no justification of what they did in Camp 7. Zero. It's like just hanging a cat for 10 days, just for the sake of it. It's just the nature, sadistic nature that I could not understand in Camp 7. I try not to think about it, honestly. It was the lowest point in my life.
但第7营里的所作所为毫无正当理由。零。就像为了吊死一只猫而吊死它，仅仅是因为那样。那种在第7营里表现出的施虐本质，我是无法理解的。说实话，我尽量不去想它。那是我人生中的最低点。
Compared to the CIA, the guards in Camp 7 could be brutally childish. Majid says they put metal and stones into his food. When he didn't return his tray in protest, they shaved his head as punishment and then took his tray altogether, just scooped the food into his hands.
与中情局相比，第7营的狱警可能表现得极其幼稚且残忍。马吉德说他们把金属和石头放进他的食物里。当他抗议不还餐盘时，他们把他剃光头作为惩罚，然后干脆把餐盘收走，直接把食物倒进他手里。
When the International Committee of the Red Cross gave him a photo of his three-year-old daughter, the first time he learned he had a daughter, a guard took the photo away from him. He says he went crazy, kicked at the door, tried to break the security camera.
当红十字国际委员会给他一张他三岁女儿的照片（那是他第一次知道自己有个女儿）时，一名狱警把照片抢走了。他说他发疯了，踢门，试图砸毁安全摄像头。
And then there were the noises, constant noises, from the guards knocking on his cell at all hours of the day and night, opening and shutting the prison doors. The building itself made noise. There were high frequency whining sounds from the air conditioners and the security cameras. There were vibrations.
还有那些噪音，狱警没日没夜地敲他牢房的门，开门又关门，声音不断。建筑物本身也会发出噪音。空调和安全摄像头的振动发出高频的嗡嗡声。有振动。
Majid was in isolation. No one to talk to, no distractions, no way to sleep. It all seemed intentional. When he talks about that time today, it still makes him upset that the guards at Gitmo drove him to the brink, to the point where he felt like he was losing his mind, just to mess with him.
马吉德被单独隔离。没有人说话，没有消遣，无法入睡。这一切似乎都是故意的。今天谈论那段时光时，他依然感到沮丧，因为关塔那摩的狱警把他逼到了崩溃边缘，逼到他觉得自己快疯了，仅仅是为了折磨他。
I remember pulling my beard, right? Literally just pulling and banging my head against the wall.
我记得我拽着自己的胡子，对吧？字面意义上，就是拽着它，把头撞在墙上。
Literally? Literally?
真的吗？字面意思？
Literally. And to this, I'll show you. This is the artery I chew. I chewed that artery right here.
字面意思。说到这个，我给你看。这是我嚼烂的动脉。我就是在这里把动脉嚼烂的。
He was so distressed and so desperate for them to treat him better that he chewed through the vein in the crook of his arm. It was the only way he could get them to pay attention to the pain he was in.
他当时非常痛苦，为了让他们对他好一点，他甚至嚼穿了手臂弯处的静脉。这是他唯一能让他们注意到他所承受的痛苦的方法。
They had to respond. His arm was gushing blood. Had to take him to the medical clinic, which meant they had to write reports, which the camp commanders would have to see.
他们不得不回应。他的手臂血流不止。不得不带他去医疗诊所，这意味着他们必须写报告，营地指挥官就会看到。
You had to act like a maniac to prove to them there is a problem.
你不得不表现得像个疯子，才能向他们证明出问题了。
Majid said other Camp 7 prisoners did the same kind of thing.
马吉德说，第7营的其他囚犯也做过类似的事情。
Majid was at Guantánamo for over a year before he met with his attorneys. He hadn't been charged with anything yet. It was possible he'd be held indefinitely or charged with crimes that could carry a life sentence.
马吉德在关塔那摩待了一年多才见到律师。他还没被指控任何罪名。他有可能被无限期关押，或者被指控面临终身监禁。
He was barely keeping it together in Camp 7. He wanted out-- of Guantánamo, of captivity. He wanted to be with his family. He told his attorneys he would take a plea deal, admit to his crimes, cooperate with the government, as long as he got the opportunity to speak in public about the torture.
他在第7营已经快撑不下去了。他想出去——离开关塔那摩，离开囚禁。他想和家人在一起。他告诉律师他愿意达成认罪协议，承认罪行，配合政府，只要能让他有机会公开谈论那些酷刑。
That's what I asked for. That was my number-one goal. Allow me to speak. Let me tell the world what they did to me.
这就是我要求的。这是我的首要目标。允许我发言。让我告诉世界他们对我做了什么。
He was pissed. Sure, he understood why the CIA had tortured him, but he also knew it was against the rules.
他很愤怒。当然，他理解中情局为什么要折磨他，但他同样知道那是违反规则的。
I was mad at that time. I was really mad. I was like, you got to pay for this. I'm going to tell the whole world about it.
我当时很生气。我真的非常生气。我想，你们必须为此付出代价。我要告诉全世界。
So, revenge-- but also, there was a practical reason he wanted to talk. He figured he could use it as leverage in his own legal case. It was a thought he'd had back in the black sites.
所以，为了复仇——但同时，他想说话还有个实际原因。他觉得可以利用这一点作为自己法律诉讼的筹码。这是他在黑狱时就有的想法。
Fun fact, the CIA told me, Majid, we can't let you go. I was like, why not? They said, look, we think if we let you go, you speak fluent English, and then you're going to tell the world how American fucked me up. And you're going to end up in Oprah show or something. And that's the problem.
趣闻，中情局曾告诉我，马吉德，我们不能放你走。我问，为什么？他们说，看，我们觉得如果我们放你走，你英语说得这么流利，你肯定会告诉世界美国是怎么把我毁了的。你会上奥普拉秀之类的。这就是问题所在。
It was very honest people, when it comes to the-- they didn't hide it, that was the problem was. It's not-- I understood it was not what I did. It's so much what they did to me.
这些人非常诚实，当涉及——他们没有隐瞒，这就是问题所在。不是关于我做了什么，而是关于他们对我做了什么。
Majid guessed that if a jury heard what the CIA had done to him firsthand, they would give him a lighter sentence.
马吉德猜测，如果陪审团亲耳听到中情局对他所做的一切，他们会给他更轻的判决。
Deep down, I knew that this was the silver bullet for me.
在内心深处，我知道这就是我的王牌。
Well, what do you mean, it was the silver bullet for you?
什么意思，这是你的王牌？
I mean, it was a ticket out of jail card, basically. It's like you can't put a person, like, 50 years in prison and plus torture, right? So it just, from my perspective, is that this was the only shot I have.
我的意思是，这基本上是一张出狱的票。就像你不能把一个人关50年监狱外加折磨，对吧？所以在我看来，这是我唯一的筹码。
He had lived in the United States long enough to absorb an American sense of justice-- from watching Law and Order, from his high school teachers. He calls it a "side effect of being American." He was making a bet that the American public, by way of an American jury, would have the same sense of American justice that he had.
他在美国生活的时间足够长，吸收了一种美国的正义感——从看《法律与秩序》、从高中老师那里。他称之为“作为美国人的副作用”。他押注的是，美国公众通过美国陪审团，会和他拥有同样的美国正义感。
The other prisoners in Camp 7 with him, Majid says they did not understand this. It's remarkable to hear Majid talk about these other prisoners in Camp 7 itself, a place that was so secret the government didn't even acknowledge its existence until 2008. No reporter has ever been there.
马吉德说，第7营和他一起的其他囚犯并不理解这一点。听到马吉德谈论第7营本身非常引人注目，那个地方极其机密，政府直到2008年才承认它的存在。从未有记者去过那里。
And then there's Majid, the only Camp 7 prisoner to ever leave Guantánamo. So he's really the only person who can speak freely about what was happening inside those highly classified walls.
而马吉德是唯一离开关塔那摩的第7营囚犯。所以他确实是唯一能自由谈论那些高度机密围墙内发生的事情的人。
The other prisoners with him were considered to be the actual worst of the worst-- high-level terrorist leaders, plotters, and soldiers like KSM. There was also Abu Zubaydah, who allegedly ran his own extremist network, associated with al-Qaeda. Another guy called Hambali, who was accused of orchestrating the 2003 Marriott bombing in Jakarta, the plot Majid delivered money for. And then there was Majid.
和他在一起的其他囚犯被认为是真正的“坏中之坏”——高层恐怖分子领导人、策划者和士兵，比如KSM。还有据称运营自己极端组织、与基地组织有关联的阿布·祖贝达。另一个叫汉巴利的家伙，被指控策划了2003年雅加达万豪酒店爆炸案，马吉德为那次阴谋送了钱。然后就是马吉德。
I was a greenhorn.
我当时是个雏儿。
The other detainees were older than Majid. He was only 23 when he was captured. Plus, he points out he hadn't done any hardcore jihadi training at the camps in Afghanistan. He hadn't shot an AK-47, or lived in a cave, or sworn an oath to bin Laden.
其他被拘留者都比马吉德年长。他被抓时才23岁。此外，他指出他并没有在阿富汗的营地里接受过任何硬核圣战训练。他没有开过AK-47，没住过山洞，也没向本·拉登宣过誓。
I was the kid on the block, right? Everybody was concerned about me because they understood that this kid has not been to Afghanistan. He doesn't know much about Islam. He doesn't know. They were worried about me. It's like, we've got to take care of this kid, you know?
我是街区里的孩子，对吧？每个人都担心我，因为他们明白这个孩子没去过阿富汗。他不懂伊斯兰教。他什么都不知道。他们为我担心。就像说，我们要照顾这个孩子，你知道吗？
And then they did. I mean, honest to God, they did. Otherwise, I don't think I would have made it. It was so terrible in Guantánamo Bay.
然后他们确实做到了。我向上帝发誓，他们真的做到了。不然，我觉得我撑不到今天。关塔那摩湾太可怕了。
Majid wanted to help them, these men he calls his prison brothers. And because he was a little bit American, he understood something they didn't. Just as Majid believed torture could be legal currency in his own case, he figured it could be helpful in theirs, too. So--
马吉德想帮助他们，这些他称之为“狱中兄弟”的人。因为他有一点美国背景，他理解一些他们不懂的东西。正如马吉德相信酷刑可以作为他自己案件中的合法筹码一样，他觉得这对他们也会有帮助。所以——
I decided to make a torture sheet.
我决定制作一张“酷刑表”。
He undertook a reporting project to document the extent of everyone's torture, on a spreadsheet he drew by hand.
他进行了一项报告项目，用他亲手绘制的电子表格记录了每个人的酷刑程度。
I wrote down all the methods that I knew were used after talking to other detainees, like waterboarding, hanging, hunger, made to sit, made to stand. I just made the whole list on the left side. And then I put all the detainee names on the rest of the page.
我写下了所有我知道在与兄弟们谈话后被使用过的方法，比如水刑、吊起来、饥饿、强迫久坐、强迫久站。我只是在左边列出了整个列表。然后在页面其余部分填上了所有被拘留者的名字。
Not everyone wanted to talk about the torture. Some of the prisoners felt that it was better left between them and God.
并非所有人都想谈论酷刑。一些囚犯觉得最好还是留给他们自己和上帝去处理。
Honestly, I had to drag it out of them. It was not that easy to even convince some of the brothers to tell me about that.
老实说，我得强迫他们说出来。要说服一些兄弟告诉我有关于那方面的事情并不容易。
I said, look, I'm just doing this project. Do it for me. They said, OK, OK. And then they start telling me all about that.
我说，看，我只是在做这个项目。为我做吧。他们说，好吧，好吧。然后他们开始告诉我关于那一切。
I think the brother didn't understand because most of them didn't live in the States. And they didn't understand how powerful-- the torture could be an asset in their legal case. Right? And I said, look, you need to-- you've got to put it down. This could be a ticket out of here. And a lot of brothers were pretty naive about this legal system because on their own experience, they had a legal system in Arab countries, which is dictatorship. So--
我觉得兄弟们不理解，因为他们大部分没住过美国。他们不明白酷刑在法律案件中有多强大，可以作为筹码。对吧？我说，看，你需要——你必须写下来。这可能是出去的票。许多兄弟对这个法律体系很天真，因为根据他们自己的经验，他们习惯了阿拉伯国家的法律体系，那是独裁统治。所以——
So it doesn't matter.
所以那没意义。
Every day we get torture in Egypt, Libya. Yeah, what's the big deal?
我们每天在埃及、利比亚都会遭受酷刑。是的，有什么大不了的？
No, this is America. You actually do have rights here, even though it doesn't seem like it right now. But there's a system out there.
不，这是美国。你在这里确实有权利，尽管现在看起来不像。但这里有一套系统。
Things had gotten a bit more relaxed in Camp 7 by then. The prisoners could talk to each other through the bean holes-- the mail-like slots in their cell doors-- which the guards left open for them. Majid would ask the other prisoners questions.
到那时，第7营的情况稍微放松了一些。囚犯们可以通过豆孔——牢门上像信箱一样的缝隙——彼此交流，狱警留着这些缝隙给他们。马吉德会问其他囚犯问题。
I said, OK, how many times waterboarding? How many days? OK, I'll remember exactly. Three months, OK.
我说，好吧，水刑多少次？多少天？好的，我会记确切。三个月，好的。
He interviewed them outside during rec time.
他在休息时间在外面采访他们。
Well, he's working out elliptical. I'm working out, and I'm doing push-ups, whatever.
好吧，他正在做椭圆机。我也在锻炼，我做俯卧撑，无论做什么。
At first, he took a legal pad with him into the rec yard. But then, he says the guards caught on, said nobody could take legal pads into the rec yard anymore.
起初，他带着法律写字板去休息场。但他说后来狱警发现了，说没人能再带写字板进去。
I said, OK, no problem. I'm not going anywhere. I'll get time with the brother. I'll interview him. So I would sometime memorize it. And then I'll go back to my cell, and I write it down. So it took a long time to complete that sheet.
我说，好的，没问题。我不去别的地方。我会和兄弟们相处。我会采访他。所以我有时会把它记在脑子里。然后我回到牢房，把它写下来。所以完成那张表花了很多时间。
He worked on it for months. Some of the stories he heard defied categorization.
他为此工作了几个月。他听到的一些故事挑战了分类。
So then I had to categorize in a way that it falls in that category, right?
所以我得按某种方式分类，让它能归入那个类别，对吧？
Do you remember an example of that?
你记得例子吗？
Like Nashiri had a unique experience, like that he was hanged for maybe 18 hours or so. And they call it-- I don't know-- like two point restrictions. Like, your hands are tied up, and your legs are tied up. Right? So there's two points of restraint. And his experience was that the restraint is one leg and two hands on top, and then another leg to the wall. So he's like just like this--
比如纳希里有独特的经历，比如他被吊了大概18个小时。他们叫它——我不知道——比如两点束缚。就像，你的手被绑着，脚被绑着。对吧？所以有两点限制。他的经历是限制一只脚和两只手在上方，然后另一只脚到墙上。所以他就像这样——
Kind of scissored out--
有点剪刀腿似的——
Scissored.
剪刀。
--with his legs.
——双腿张开。
Yeah, so he can't move right, left. So that was unique. I just remember it was unique. I didn't even put it in there. I was like, OK, I made a side note.
是的，所以他不能左右移动。所以那是独特的。我记得它是独特的。我甚至没把它写进去。我心想，好吧，我做个旁注。
One of his interviews in particular stuck with him. Mustafa al Hawsawi, one of the 9/11 defendants accused of sending money to the 9/11 hijackers.
其中一个采访特别让他印象深刻。穆斯塔法·哈萨维，9/11事件被告之一，被指控给9/11劫机者汇款。
I asked him, what was the worst torture? And he said, before I answer that, he said, I'll tell you what was the best torture for me. And I said, what does that mean? He said, look, the best one, when they put me in a coffin and they filled it with water, right? And you can just literally just-- or they put me inside of a box with the bugs and everything. He said, I loved it.
我问他，最糟糕的酷刑是什么？他说，在我回答之前，我告诉你对我来说最好的酷刑是什么。我说，那是什么意思？他说，看，最好的一个，是他们把我放进棺材，里面装满水，对吧？你可以真的只——或者他们把我关进一个装满虫子什么的盒子里。他说，我喜欢它。
I said, why? He said, that was the only time I felt that I was not naked. For him, being naked in front of a man or woman, that was the most torture to him.
我问，为什么？他说，那是我唯一感觉到自己没有赤身裸体的时候。对他来说，在男人或女人面前赤身裸体，对他来说是最严重的酷刑。
By the end of the project, Majid felt he had done something great. He had a record of the torture the United States government was so intent on keeping secret.
到项目结束时，马吉德觉得他做了一件大事。他记录下了美国政府一心想保守秘密的酷刑记录。
I thought that this could be the breakthrough that we were looking for in our lives, that it could alleviate some of the pain that the camp were doing to us.
我以为这可能就是我们生活中一直在寻找的突破口，它能缓解营地对我们造成的痛苦。
He kept the spreadsheet in his cell, hoping to share it in court someday.
他把那个电子表格保存在牢房里，希望有一天能在法庭上分享。
Majid's attorney spent years working on a plea deal. Finally, in 2012, they reached an agreement. Majid would plead guilty to five charges, including murder, conspiracy, and spying, and he would cooperate with the prosecution, help them in their cases against the other prisoners.
马吉德的律师花了几年时间研究认罪协议。最终，在2012年，他们达成了一致。马吉德将承认包括谋杀、串谋和间谍罪在内的五项指控，并将配合检方，协助他们审理针对其他囚犯的案件。
In return, he would get a reduced sentence, a maximum of 19 years. And, crucially for Majid, he would finally get to speak to tell the story of his torture in court.
作为回报，他将获得减刑，最高19年。对马吉德来说至关重要的是，他终于可以开口在法庭上讲述他遭受酷刑的故事。
Majid talked to the other Camp 7 prisoners about the plea deal. He told me some of them were against it, but KSM gave him his blessing.
马吉德和第7营的其他囚犯谈过认罪协议。他告诉我有些人反对，但KSM给了他祝福。
But he said, yeah, I'm happy for you. Because he told me, look, I feel sorry for you. I've killed 3,000 people. Who the fuck are you? You're nobody in the chain of command.
但他确实说，是的，我为你高兴。因为他告诉我说，看，我为你感到难过。我杀了3000人。你算个什么东西？你在指挥链里什么都不是。
I don't know how Majid cooperated, what information he gave the American government to fulfill his end of the bargain. He told me it wasn't much, but a prosecutor in the case told me that he did confess to plots the United States government didn't even know about yet.
我不知道马吉德是怎么配合的，他给美国政府提供了什么信息来履行协议。他告诉我没多少，但案子的一名检察官告诉我，他确实承认了美国政府甚至还不知道的阴谋。
After a decade of cooperation, it was time for Majid to be sentenced in front of a judge. But before he did that, he and his defense team had one more card to play. I guess you could call it the torture card. They would turn the years of captivity and abuse in the black sites to Majid's advantage.
经过十年的配合，马吉德终于要在法官面前接受判决了。但在那之前，他和辩护团队还有最后一张牌要打。我想你可以称之为“酷刑牌”。他们要把在黑狱中遭受的多年囚禁和虐待转化为马吉德的优势。
According to the rules of the military commissions, and to Majid's plea agreement, Majid could call witnesses to support his case that he should get leniency. By then, many of the darkest details of the CIA's torture program had been revealed-- waterboarding, the destruction of videotapes of the torture, even the death of a prisoner at the salt pit, a black site where Majid was once held.
根据军事委员会的规则和马吉德的认罪协议，马吉德可以传唤证人来支持他应该获得宽大处理的理由。到那时，中情局酷刑计划的许多最黑暗的细节都已经被披露了——水刑、销毁酷刑录像带，甚至是在马吉德曾被关押的“盐坑”（一个黑狱）中一名囚犯的死亡。
But what were still a secret-- are still a closely guarded secret to this day-- are the identities of the torturers themselves. Majid's lawyers knew that the CIA did not want those names revealed-- ever, so they made that part of their strategy. His attorneys submitted a list of 115 people they wanted to call to the stand.
但仍然保密——直到今天仍是严加保守的秘密——是施暴者本人的身份。马吉德的律师知道中情局绝不想让这些名字被披露——永远不想，所以他们把这作为了策略的一部分。他的律师提交了一份他们想传唤到证人席上的115人名单。
Some of the names were far-fetched. George Bush was on it, along with Condoleezza Rice. Some were lower level, like Camp 7 commanders and FBI agents who spent time with Majid at Guantánamo.
有些名字非常牵强。乔治·布什在上面，还有康多莉扎·赖斯。有些是低级别的，比如第7营的指挥官和在关塔那摩陪伴过马吉德的联邦调查局特工。
But most importantly, the list included the people who were involved in the CIA's rendition, detention, and interrogation program, the torture program, the people who conceived of it, who ran it, and the people who tortured Majid. Majid and his defense team wanted to put the entire government apparatus responsible for the torture program on the stand.
但最重要的是，名单包括那些参与了中情局引渡、拘留和审讯计划（酷刑计划）的人，即那些构思它、运营它，以及折磨马吉德的人。马吉德和他的辩护团队想让整个负责酷刑计划的政府机构站在被告席上。
Unsurprisingly, a legal battle ensued. After years of motions and responses to motions, and bickering, and the intrusion of COVID, the judge finally ruled, said Majid could ask for time off his sentence because of the torture, and he could call some of the CIA witnesses. It was a major decision in Majid's favor.
不出所料，一场法律战随之而来。经过几年的动议和回复、争吵以及新冠疫情的干扰，法官最终做出了裁决，说马吉德可以因为酷刑请求减刑，并且可以传唤一些中情局证人。这是对马吉德有利的一项重大决定。
The government's hands were tied. They were never going to be able to produce the CIA witnesses. The CIA would make sure of that.
政府束手无策。他们永远无法带出这些中情局证人。中情局会确保这一点。
So instead, the two sides agreed. Majid would drop the whole witness testimony thing if the government would shave eight years off his sentence. Eight years-- it was a lot. Plus, the judge gave Majid another year off to ding the prosecution for discovery violation. So that made nine years total.
所以双方达成了一致。马吉德如果政府从他的刑期中削减八年，他就放弃证人作证的事。八年——这很多。另外，法官给了马吉德额外一年减刑，以惩罚检方在证据披露上的违规行为。所以总共减了九年。
I mean, shaving off nine years, you can imagine how desperate were they, 'cause they know they were fucked.
我的意思是，减了九年，你可以想象他们有多绝望，因为他们知道他们搞砸了。
What this meant, if all went according to plan, was that Majid would get out just four months after the sentencing hearing. And he would finally get to read his statement in court about what the American government had done to him, which he and his attorneys would write carefully to make sure the government couldn't classify it.
这意味着，如果一切按计划进行，马吉德将在判决听证会后仅四个月出狱。他终于可以宣读他在法庭上关于美国政府对他所做一切的陈述，他和律师会仔细撰写，以确保政府无法将其归类为机密。
The one thing he wouldn't get? He wouldn't get to talk about the torture other prisoners had undergone at CIA black sites-- everything he'd recorded in that spreadsheet-- because that might give the government a reason to classify his statement. What Majid could do was tell his own experience as completely as possible. That was the best way he could represent what they'd all gone through.
他得不到的一件事是什么？他没能谈论其他囚犯在中情局黑狱中遭受的酷刑——也就是他记录在电子表格里的那些——因为那可能给政府理由将他的陈述列为机密。马吉德能做的就是尽可能完整地讲述他自己的经历。这是他代表所有人经历的最佳方式。
Nearly two decades after Majid was captured at his brother's apartment in Karachi, his day in court was finally scheduled. According to the rules of the military commissions, a jury would be present for Majid's sentencing hearing. They would be told Majid had pled guilty. They would be told about his crimes-- the money for the hotel bombing, the assassination attempt on Musharraf, his work for al-Qaeda.
在马吉德于卡拉奇兄弟的公寓被捕近二十年后，他的法庭时间终于定下来了。根据军事委员会的规则，陪审团将出席马吉德的判决听证会。他们会被告知马吉德已经认罪。他们会被告知他的罪行——酒店爆炸案的钱、对穆沙拉夫的暗杀企图、他为基地组织所做的工作。
But-- and I know how strange this sounds-- they would not be told that Majid and the government had already come to an agreement. Instead, they'd be told to consider Majid's crimes alongside whatever Majid had to say for himself and come up with an appropriate sentence. Whatever the jury came back with, whether it was a short sentence or long, it wouldn't have a material effect on Majid's case. His sentence was set. But their decision would have symbolic meaning.
但是——我知道这听起来多奇怪——他们不会被告知马吉德和政府已经达成了协议。相反，他们会被告知考虑马吉德的罪行以及马吉德想为自己说的一切，并提出一个适当的判决。无论陪审团带回什么决定，无论是短刑还是长刑，都不会对马吉德的案件产生实质影响。他的刑期已经定了。但他们的决定具有象征意义。
This would be the first time a prisoner of the CIA's black sites would speak about his treatment in public. There might never be another reckoning for the crimes of that era-- not in a legal way, at least. The jury would weigh the two ledgers-- what Majid did against what we did to Majid-- and decide for Majid, for the country, where justice lies. It's what Majid had been hoping for so many years.
这将是中情局黑狱的囚犯第一次公开谈论他的遭遇。那个时代的罪行可能永远不会再有清算了——至少在法律层面上不会。陪审团将权衡这两笔账——马吉德所做的与我们对马吉德所做的——并为马吉德、为国家决定正义所在。这是马吉德这么多年来一直期待的。
But now that it was finally happening, he worried that he was too late. It was 2021. The country had moved on. The existential battle of the day was with COVID, not al-Qaeda. Majid worried that the only reason the government was letting him talk was that nobody really cared anymore.
但现在这一切终于发生时，他担心自己太晚了。那是2021年。国家已经向前看了。当下的存在主义之战是针对新冠，而不是基地组织。马吉德担心政府让他说话的唯一原因是没人真正在乎了。
I think at this stage, I think CIA and the Americans know that Americans lost interest, right? Honestly, being really pragmatic about it, they lost interest. They know it happens. Bad shit happened.
我觉得在这个阶段，我觉得中情局和美国人知道美国人失去了兴趣，对吧？老实说，从务实的角度来看，他们失去了兴趣。他们知道发生了。糟糕的事情发生了。
And it's almost like they had created a tolerance for this that is almost-- how do you say-- desensitized to torture now. And it's a fact.
这几乎就像他们创造了一种对这种事情的容忍度，几乎——怎么说呢——对酷刑脱敏了。这是一个事实。
And I think that's what the CIA is like, fuck it. Let him speak. I don't think they care anymore, honestly. What's the big deal? Waterboarding? We already heard it 100 times.
我想这就是中情局的感觉，去他的。让他说吧。我不认为他们还在乎了，老实说。有什么大不了的？水刑？我们已经听过100遍了。
So will they care?
那么他们会在乎吗？
Dana Chivvis. Coming up, Majid finally gets his day in court. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我是达娜·奇维斯。接下来，马吉德终于在法庭上有了他的一天。那将在稍后的芝加哥公共广播电台节目中继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Two Ledgers." We're playing an episode from the new season of Serial, which is all about Guantánamo. Dana Chivvis picks up the story of Majid Khan where she left off, on the day of his sentencing hearing.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“两笔账”。我们要播放《Serial》新季的一集，全季内容都围绕关塔那摩。达娜·奇维斯将从判决听证会那天接续马吉德·汗的故事。
The courtroom at Guantanamo is a long, windowless rectangle with six rows of defense tables on the left, mirrored by four rows of prosecution tables on the right. It looks like any other sterile courtroom, except in the back, there's a gallery separated by a thick wall of glass and a 40-second audio delay. That's where the press and the public sit.
关塔那摩的法庭是一个长方形、无窗的房间，左侧有六排辩护桌，右侧对应着四排检方桌。它看起来像任何其他无菌的法庭，除了在后面，有一个由厚玻璃墙和40秒音频延迟隔开的画廊。那是媒体和公众坐的地方。
On this day, October 28, 2021, that's where Majid's father and sister are seated. Majid had been allowed to see them earlier that morning for the first time in 19 years.
在2021年10月28日这一天，马吉德的父亲和姐姐就坐在那里。马吉德那天早上被允许在19年来第一次见到他们。
Did anything surprise you in that meeting about either one of them or about how you felt or how they acted?
在那个会面中，有没有什么让你感到惊讶的关于他们中的任何一个，或者关于你的感受，或者他们的表现？
Well, the first thing, I was like, they're short. I was like, did I get tall, or is like-- or they're shorter? 'Cause I thought they were about my size.
嗯，第一件事是，我想，他们变矮了。我想，是我长高了，还是——他们变矮了？因为我以为他们和我差不多大。
This hearing would be the first time they learned the details of Majid's imprisonment. There is no publicly available recording of this hearing, but I do have the transcripts, and I've spoken with several people who were there that day.
这次听证会将是他们第一次了解马吉德监禁的细节。这次听证会没有公开录音，但我有文字记录，而且我也和当天在那里的一些人交谈过。
Majid sits at the front of the courtroom at a defendant's table with four of his attorneys. Court starts at 9:06 AM. The lawyers spend most of the day selecting the jury-- not a jury of Majid's peers, not even civilians. In this military court, the jury consists of eight senior officers from across the armed forces, which, if you were once in al-Qaeda, tough room.
马吉德坐在法庭前排的被告桌上，和他的四名律师在一起。法庭在早上9:06开始。律师们花了一天大部分时间挑选陪审团——不是马吉德的同龄人陪审团，甚至不是平民。在这个军事法庭里，陪审团由武装部队的八名高级军官组成，如果一个人曾经在基地组织待过，这可真是个难搞的房间。
The sentencing proceedings don't really get going until after 5:00. A prosecutor reads the stipulation of fact to the jury, the document that describes in cold legalese all the crimes Majid has admitted to. It's dispassionate, but detailed, and it's damning. The story of a young man given asylum by the United States who turns his back on the country and his family to join the terrorists who attacked us, with hopes of attacking us again.
判决程序直到5:00之后才真正开始。一名检察官向陪审团宣读了事实说明书，这是一份用冰冷的法律用语描述马吉德承认的所有罪行的文件。它冷静但详细，而且令人愤慨。这是一个接受美国庇护的年轻人背弃国家和家庭，加入袭击我们的恐怖分子，并希望再次袭击我们的故事。
After the prosecutor finishes reading the stipulation of fact, they break for dinner. And then finally, at around 7:40 PM, Majid, in a black suit and tie his lawyers bought him, steps up to the podium, 39-page statement in hand, and faces the military jury in their dress uniforms.
检察官宣读完事实说明书后，他们休息吃饭。然后终于，在晚上7:40左右，马吉德穿着律师为他买的黑色西装和领带，走上讲台，手里拿着39页的陈述书，面对着穿着礼服的军事陪审团。
He's nervous. This is the moment he's been thinking about for 18 years. But it's late. He's tired. His back is killing him.
他很紧张。这是他18年来一直在思考的时刻。但时间太晚了。他很累。他的背痛得要命。
The judge says, "And, Mr. Khan, you may proceed." Majid proceeds.
法官说：“汗先生，你可以继续。”马吉德继续。
"I begin in name of God. My name is Majid Khan. And for the last 15 years, I have been incarcerated at Naval Station Guantánamo Bay, or Gitmo."
“我以神之名开始。我的名字是马吉德·汗。在过去的15年里，我一直被监禁在关塔那摩湾海军基地，也就是吉特摩。”
Majid read some of his statement for me.
马吉德为我读了他陈述书的一部分。
"I have a story that I have waited almost two decades to tell, so I want to start by thanking you all for taking the time to listen to my statement. Today, I stand before you, meek and humble, humble and meek, asking for you to listen to my story with a sensitive and compassionate ear."
“我有一个故事，我等了将近二十年才讲出来，所以我想先谢谢你们花时间听我的陈述。今天，我谦卑地站在这里，请求你们以敏感和同情的心听我的故事。”
Majid takes responsibility for his crimes and apologizes to his family. He explains to the jury how he ended up in al-Qaeda, how, after returning to Baltimore in 2002, his family tried to keep him from going back to Pakistan because they were afraid of what he'd gotten involved in there, how his father hid his travel documents, how he lied to his father to get them back.
马吉德为自己的罪行负责并向家人道歉。他向陪审团解释了自己是如何陷入基地组织的，如何在2002年回到巴尔的摩后，家人试图阻止他回巴基斯坦，因为他们害怕他参与其中的事，他的父亲藏起了他的旅行证件，他是如何对父亲撒谎拿回证件的。
"He's here in court today. I can see him. I want to tell him, Baba, I'm sorry. I'm very sorry."
“他今天就在法庭上。我能看见他。我想告诉他，爸爸，对不起。我真的很抱歉。”
And then Majid recounts everything the CIA did to him in detail for two hours, hoping that by saying what happened to him personally, he can overcome the apathy to torture, the disgust for al-Qaeda. Because it's one thing to read about torture on a page, and another to be faced with the person who endured it, 20 feet away, describing it to you.
然后马吉德详细讲述了中情局对他所做的一切，持续了两个小时，希望通过说出他个人发生的事情，能够克服对酷刑的冷漠、对基地组织的厌恶。因为在纸上读到酷刑是一回事，而面对遭受酷刑的人，在20英尺外，描述给你们听又是另一回事。
He starts the day he was captured, picking up where the stipulation of fact drops off. He describes how the Pakistani authorities took him to a lockup, interrogated him, how there were Americans there, too, how the Pakistanis beat him-- the first time he was ever beaten.
他从被捕那天开始讲起，接着事实说明书之后。他描述了巴基斯坦当局如何把他带到一个拘留所，审讯他，那里也有美国人，巴基斯坦人如何殴打他——他第一次被殴打。
"I was frequently hooded and strapped into metal boots. Now, these metal boots were-- I call them ski metal boots, about this high. They would make me stand on those metal boots, and they are punching me and beating me up. I remember fearing that if I had fell over forward, there was no doubt my leg would snap. I was so afraid of what would happen next.
“我经常被戴上头套并捆在金属靴子里。现在，这些金属靴子是——我叫它们金属滑雪靴，大概这么高。他们让我站在那些金属靴子上，他们对我拳打脚踢。我记得我害怕如果我向前倒下，我的腿肯定会断。我非常害怕接下来会发生什么。”
I remember an older American, a US interrogator, who would tell me they were not buying my story. Quote, 'You're peeing on my shoes and telling me it's raining,' end of quote.
“我记得一个年长的美国人，一名美国审讯官，他告诉我他们不相信我的故事。引用，‘你在我鞋上撒尿，却告诉我是在下雨’，结束引用。”
This man would frequently threaten me, saying, like, 'Son, we're going to take care of you. We are going to send you to a place that you cannot imagine. We'll take you somewhere and make you talk,' end of quote. He threatened my family, and he threatened to rape my sister."
“这个人经常威胁我，说，就像，‘孩子，我们会处理你的。我们会把你送到一个你无法想象的地方。我们会带你去某处让你开口’，结束引用。他威胁我的家人，还威胁要强奸我的姐姐。”
Majid tells the jury about the day his Pakistani guard said he was going home, but instead, he was taken to an airport and handed over to the CIA. How the Americans cut his clothes off him, gave him an enema, put him in a diaper, and duct-taped goggles and earmuffs to his head. And then they flew him to another country.
马吉德告诉陪审团，巴基斯坦狱警说他要回家那天，他反而被带到机场移交给了中情局。美国人剪掉他的衣服，给他灌肠，穿上尿布，用胶带把护目镜和耳罩粘在他头上。然后他们把他飞到另一个国家。
He describes the black site he calls "the American torture place." The windows of the American torture place were covered in cloth, and there was techno music blasting.
他描述了他称之为“美国酷刑处”的黑狱。美国酷刑处的窗户蒙着布，播放着电音。
An interrogator in a black mask asked him questions about al-Qaeda plots in the United States and at Heathrow Airport. And when he wasn't satisfied with Majid's answers, he counted down on his fingers from 10. At zero, a guard grabbed the chains around Majid's hands, threw them over a wooden beam in the ceiling, and hoisted Majid into the air.
一个戴着黑色面具的审讯官问他关于基地组织在美国和希思罗机场的阴谋的问题。当他对马吉德的回答不满意时，他从10开始倒数。到0时，一名狱警抓住马吉德手上的链子，把它扔过天花板上的一根木梁，把马吉德吊到了空中。
"With sudden movement, the guards had hoisted the chain attached to my hands and pulled the chain tight. After a few more pulls, I was hanging by my hands with my shackled feet barely touching the ground. The interrogators left the room as I screamed in pain and tried to support my weight. After a while, the interrogator--"
“随着突然的移动，狱警拉紧了连着我手的链子。又拉了几下后，我被吊在半空中，戴着镣铐的双脚勉强触地。审讯官离开房间时，我在剧痛中尖叫，试图支撑自己的重量。过了一会儿，审讯官——”
Majid tells the jury they left him hanging like that for an hour or two, and then dragged him into a tiled bathroom to a bathtub filled with ice water.
马吉德告诉陪审团，他们把他像那样吊着挂了一两个小时，然后把他拖进一个铺满瓷砖的浴室，那里有一个装满冰水的浴缸。
"The US interrogator placed me feet first into the ice water and then pushed my body flat to the bottom of the tub. I was still wearing a thin cloth hood. While some US interrogators held my body under the water, the lead interrogator pushed my head under the water and held me down as I struggle against drowning. As I gasped for air, the interrogator would demand answer to the questions.
“美国审讯官把我脚朝下放进冰水里，然后把我的身体推到底部。我还戴着薄布头套。当一些美国审讯官把我的身体按在水下时，首席审讯官把我的头按进水里，在我挣扎着溺水时按住我。当我喘气时，审讯官会要求回答问题。”
They repeatedly submerged me. When I could get air, I would beg them to stop and swear to them that I did not know anything."
“他们反复把我淹没。当我可以呼吸时，我会求他们停止，并向他们发誓我什么都不知道。”
The people I talked to who were in court that day said Majid was stoic as he read his statement. Sometimes he acted out the scene he was describing. Like when he talked about being hung from a beam, he put his arms up into the air. He pointed out the scars on his ankles when he told the jury how his feet swelled so much, the ankle cuffs cut into his skin.
那天在法庭上的人说，马吉德读陈述时面无表情。有时他表演了他所描述的场景。比如当他谈到被吊在横梁上时，他把双臂举到空中。他指着脚踝上的伤疤，告诉陪审团他的脚肿得很厉害，脚镣割破了皮肤。
Different details from his statement lodged in different people's heads. For the prosecutor, Colonel Walt Foster, it was hearing how Majid was strung up by his arms. For Majid's attorney, Major Michael Lyness, it was the bugs.
他陈述中的不同细节留在了不同人的脑海中。对于检察官沃尔特·福斯特上校来说，是听到马吉德被双臂吊起来；对于马吉德的律师迈克尔·莱尼斯少校来说，是那些虫子。
"But I could feel tiny bugs, smaller than mosquitoes, biting me repeatedly until I bled. With my hands shackled, I couldn't swat the bugs or scratch the sores they left."
“但我能感觉到微小的虫子，比蚊子还小，反复叮咬我，直到我流血。戴着镣铐，我无法拍打它们，也无法抓挠它们留下的疮口。”
There's one person from the black sites who Majid refers to specifically in his statement, gives him a nickname, a man he calls the "torture doctor." In April 2004, Majid tells the jury, he was moved to a different black site, which he refers to as "long-term CIA prison." He realized nobody was coming to help him. He was on his own.
马吉德在陈述中专门提到黑狱的一个人，给他起了个外号，他称之为“酷刑医生”。马吉德告诉陪审团，2004年4月，他被转移到另一个黑狱，他称之为“长期中情局监狱”。他意识到没人会来帮他。他孤身一人。
He started a hunger strike to protest. So the torture doctor and the guards force fed him, sometimes with an IV, sometimes with a tube up the nose and down the throat.
他开始绝食以示抗议。所以酷刑医生和狱警强迫他进食，有时用静脉注射，有时用管子从鼻孔插到喉咙。
"I remember the torture doctor right in front of me. He would take the tube, and he would sharpen the tube and put a hot sauce. And then he would nose feed me."
“我记得酷刑医生就在我面前。他拿着管子，把管子削尖，涂上辣酱。然后他用鼻子喂我。”
And then when that didn't break his will, when he continued to hunger strike--
当那没能击垮他的意志，当他继续绝食时——
"After the force feeding failed to get me to cooperate, they returned to torture me. This part is extremely painful to talk about as a Muslim and in front of my parents and my sister. In the month of September 2004, still at long-term CIA prison, I was raped by a CIA torture doctor while being restrained.
“在强迫进食没能让我配合后，他们又回来折磨我。作为一个穆斯林，在我的父母和姐姐面前谈论这一部分极其痛苦。2004年9月，还在长期中情局监狱，我在被束缚的情况下被一名中情局酷刑医生强奸了。”
They did it in my cell. I was restrained very tightly and secured by at least two guards. The CIA torture doctor was there to administer the insertion, but it was not a medical procedure.
“他们在我的牢房里做这件事。我被束缚得很紧，由至少两名狱警固定住。中情局酷刑医生在那儿实施插入，但那不是医疗程序。”
I remember one time in my cell, I asked this torture doctor why he was doing this, and he whispered with viciousness. And he said, quote, 'You're a fucking terrorist,' end of quote. I swear to God, I remember exact words. He grabbed me like this, and he says, 'You're a fucking terrorist.'
“我记得有一次在牢房里，我问这个酷刑医生为什么要这样做，他恶毒地低语道。他说，引用，‘你是个该死的恐怖分子’，结束引用。我向上帝发誓，我记得确切的话。他像这样抓住我，他说，‘你是个该死的恐怖分子’。”
This is the hardest part. They used green garden hoses, regular-sized hoses connected to one side to my rectum, another one to the faucet. And they would turn on the water. And I could feel the gush of water going into my rectum. I remember feeling immense pressure in my bowels, a pain I had never felt."
“这是最难的部分。他们用绿色花园水管，普通的管子，一头接到我的直肠，另一头接到水龙头。他们打开水。我能感觉到水涌入我的直肠。我记得感受到肠道极大的压力，那种痛苦我从未感受过。”
The CIA euphemistically called this "rectal rehydration." They didn't stop at water. Once, the torture doctor and the guards bound Majid with duct tape and shackles and put two bottles of Ensure into his rectum. And then, later that same day, they puréed Majid's entire lunch tray-- hummus, pasta, sauce, nuts, and raisins-- and inserted all of that into his rectum, too.
中情局委婉地称之为“直肠补液”。他们不仅仅用水。有一次，酷刑医生和狱警用胶带和镣铐绑住马吉德，把两瓶Ensure营养品塞进他的直肠。然后，同一天晚些时候，他们把马吉德的整盘午餐——鹰嘴豆泥、意大利面、酱汁、坚果和葡萄干——全部打碎，也插进了他的直肠。
This was known as rectal feeding. The body cannot absorb nutrients this way. So a more accurate word for it is rape. At least five other CIA prisoners were raped this way, too, according to the Senate report.
这被称为“直肠喂食”。身体不能通过这种方式吸收营养。所以更准确的词是“强奸”。据参议院报告，至少还有五名中情局囚犯也以这种方式被强奸。
On page 30 of his 39-page statement, Majid stops reading and takes a sip of water. He tells the jury apologetically that he's nearly done, asks them to bear with him. The judge says, would you like to take a break, Mr. Khan? And Majid says, Judge, I would like to get it over with-- thanks him for his concern.
在他39页陈述书的第30页，马吉德停止阅读，喝了一口水。他抱歉地告诉陪审团他快读完了，请他们忍受一下。法官说，汗先生，你想休息一下吗？马吉德说，法官，我想赶紧结束——谢谢他的关心。
He picks back up in May of 2006, when things had started to change in CIA custody, ease up a little. He went on a hunger strike again. But this time, the Americans didn't punish him, didn't rape him. He told them he was depressed, and they offered him Prozac.
他从2006年5月继续读起，那时中情局监护下的事情开始改变，稍微轻松了一点。他又开始绝食了。但这次，美国人没有惩罚他，没有强奸他。他告诉他们他抑郁了，他们给了他百忧解。
Majid tells the jury how, in September of 2006, he was transferred to Guantánamo, how, on the plane ride there, he felt, for the first time, like he might actually survive. But then he was put in Camp 7. He describes his treatment there, the noises, the cruelty of the guards.
马吉德告诉陪审团，2006年9月，他被转移到关塔那摩，在去那里的飞机上，他第一次觉得他可能真的能活下来。但随后他被关进了第7营。他描述了在那里的待遇，噪音，狱警的残酷。
Here, he goes off script. Tells the jury that this is just a, quote, "summary of the summary of the summary of the summary." That he has 600 pages of notes about his treatment at Guantánamo, but he doesn't want to bore them.
在这里，他脱离了稿子。告诉陪审团这只是一个，引用，“关于关于关于关于的摘要”。他有600页关于他在关塔那摩所受待遇的笔记，但他不想让他们厌烦。
And then he wraps it up, thanks his attorneys, takes responsibility for his actions and his crimes, and apologizes to everyone he's hurt, including his wife, Rabia, and his daughter, Manaal, whom he's never met. He apologizes to his father again, and to his siblings, apologizes for abandoning them after their mother died.
然后他收尾，感谢他的律师，为自己的行为和罪行负责，并向他伤害过的所有人道歉，包括他的妻子拉比亚和从未见过面的女儿曼娜尔。他再次向父亲和兄弟姐妹道歉，为母亲去世后遗弃他们道歉。
"I have wanted to tell my story for a very long time. I am so very appreciative for your attention. Thank you for letting me share it with you today."
“我想讲我的故事已经很久了。我非常感谢你们的关注。谢谢你们今天让我与你们分享它。”
At this point, Majid's been reading for two hours non-stop. He says, God bless, and walks back to his seat. By all accounts of the people I've talked to, the jury listened to Majid's statement like statues, unmoving.
此时，马吉德已经不停读了两个小时。他说，上帝保佑，走回了他的座位。据我交谈过的人所说，陪审团像雕像一样听着马吉德的陈述，纹丝不动。
The next day, Colonel Foster, the prosecutor, gives a closing statement for the government. He tries to refocus the trial around the crimes of Majid Khan, rather than the crimes of the United States government. He talks about the victims of the Jakarta bombing, who've been off stage for most of the hearing, and reads their names out loud.
第二天，检察官沃尔特·福斯特上校代表政府做了最后陈述。他试图将审判重新聚焦于马吉德·汗的罪行，而不是美国政府的罪行。他谈到了雅加达爆炸案的受害者，他们在大部分听证会中都未提及，并大声读出了他们的名字。
Colonel Foster plays down the torture, saying, quote, "I would concur that Mr. Khan received extremely rough treatment by the individuals that detained him, and it is right for you to consider that conduct. However, despite what Mr. Khan experienced, he is still alive and with us here today, a luxury that the dead and the 11 victims of the JW Marriott Hotel bombing do not have."
福斯特上校淡化了酷刑，说道：“我同意汗先生受到了拘留者极其粗暴的对待，你们考虑这种行为是正确的。然而，尽管汗先生经历了什么，他依然活着，今天和我们在一起，这是死者和JW万豪酒店爆炸案的11名受害者所没有的奢侈。”
The jury can choose a sentence anywhere from 25 to 40 years. Colonel Foster asked them to sentence him in the upper range of the spectrum. Major Michael Lyness, one of Majid's defense attorneys, gives a rebuttal. He asks the jury to give Majid 25 years.
陪审团可以选择25到40年之间的刑期。福斯特上校要求判处他处于该范围的高端。马吉德的一名辩护律师迈克尔·莱尼斯少校进行了反驳。他请求陪审团判处马吉德25年。
And then the judge sends him off to deliberate. They're gone for three hours. When they come back, the judge asks Majid to stand, and the foreman reads a sentence. Quote, "Majid Shoukhat Khan, this military commission sentences you to be confined for 26 years, zero months, zero days."
然后法官让他们去审议。他们离开了三个小时。回来时，法官让马吉德起立，领班宣读了判决。引用，“马吉德·舒卡特·汗，本军事委员会判处你监禁26年，零个月，零天。”
Again, Majid doesn't have to serve all this time. His sentence is already set. But 26 years, it's only one year more than the minimum. It's proof that Majid was right to bet that a jury of Americans would give him a lighter sentence once they heard about the torture.
同样，马吉德不必服满这段时间。他的刑期已经定了。但26年，只比最低限度多一年。这证明马吉德押注陪审团的美国人一旦听到酷刑就会给他更轻的判决是正确的。
The judge thanks the jury, reminds them not to talk about their deliberations. And then, just as he's about to excuse them, the foreman indicates he has something else to say. He has a letter for the defense team. He hands the letter to the bailiff, who walks over and gives it to Majid's attorney, Major Lyness, who leaves it there on the desk, tantalizingly folded in half while the judge wraps up the session.
法官感谢了陪审团，提醒他们不要谈论他们的审议。然后，就在他准备解散他们时，领班示意他还有话要说。他有一封给辩护团队的信。他把信交给法警，法警走过去把它给了马吉德的律师莱尼斯少校，他在法官结束会议时把它放在桌上，折成两半诱人地放着。
We wanted to open right away. Right? And everybody is acting like it's not a big deal, nonchalant.
我们想立刻打开它。对吧？每个人都装作这不是什么大事，无动于衷。
The judge finally says, Mr. Khan, I wish you all the best in the future. This court is adjourned.
法官最终说，汗先生，我祝你未来一切顺利。本庭休庭。
And then once the judge left the building, like a pack of dogs, attacked that letter. I was like, let me read it. It's my letter. It's like, let me hold it.
然后一旦法官离开大楼，像一群狗一样，扑向那封信。我说，让我读一下。这是我的信。就像，让我拿一下。
The letter is written in tidy handwriting on lined paper. It reads, quote, "The panel members listed below recommend clemency in the case of Majid Shoukhat Khan." It's a letter to the so-called "Convening Authority." That's the person who's the final arbiter of Majid's case. It's a military justice thing. I'm not going to explain.
信是用整齐的字迹写在横线纸上的。上面写着，引用，“下列委员会成员建议对马吉德·舒卡特·汗案减刑。”这是一封写给所谓的“召集人”的信。那是最终决定马吉德案件的人。那是军事司法的事情。我不打算解释。
It's a letter asking the Convening Authority to go easy on Majid. It says Majid should get leniency because he was denied due process, because he was a young man when he committed his crimes and is no longer a threat for future extremism, and because he was so badly abused by the United States.
这是一封要求召集人对马吉德宽大处理的信。它说马吉德应该获得宽大处理，因为他被剥夺了正当程序，因为他犯罪时是个年轻人，现在不再构成未来极端主义的威胁，而且因为他遭到了美国的严重虐待。
Quote, "This abuse was of no practical value in terms of intelligence or any other tangible benefit to US interests. Instead, it is a stain on the moral fiber of America." It's signed by seven of the eight jury members, all officers of the United States military, all serving during the global war on terrorism, and who, having compared the two ledgers, rendered their verdict on this era of American history. What Majid did was bad, but what we did to him was punishment enough.
引用，“这种虐待在情报或任何其他对美国利益的切身利益方面毫无实际价值。相反，这是对美国道德准则的玷污。”这封信由八名陪审团成员中的七名签署，他们都是美国军队的军官，都在全球反恐战争期间服役，在权衡了这两笔账后，对这一段美国历史做出了他们的判决。马吉德所做的是错的，但我们对他所做的一切已经是足够的惩罚。
I think for lots of people in the military, this conclusion will not come as a surprise. This idea of torturing prisoners isn't some abstract moral debate for them. It's personal, practical.
我想对于军队中的许多人来说，这个结论并不令人惊讶。这种折磨囚犯的想法对他们来说不是什么抽象的道德辩论。这是个人的、实际的。
If they get captured by the enemy, they don't want to be tortured. They don't want other Americans to be tortured. They want that kind of thing to be out of bounds. They need the US to hold the line.
如果他们被敌人俘虏，他们不想被折磨。他们不想让其他美国人被折磨。他们希望这种事情是不允许的。他们需要美国坚守底线。
The clemency letter is framed on my wall in my office.
那封减刑信现在挂在我办公室的墙上。
That's Major Lyness, one of Majid's defense attorneys.
那是莱尼斯少校，马吉德的辩护律师之一。
And the original document is in my closet. And I still don't know what to do with it. I don't know who-- does the National Archives want this original document? Because it's currently just in my closet.
原件在我的壁橱里。但我还是不知道该拿它怎么办。我不知道谁——国家档案馆想要这个原件吗？因为它目前就躺在我的壁橱里。
Why didn't you frame the original on your office wall? Why is that the one in the closet?
你为什么不把原件挂在办公室墙上？为什么那个在壁橱里？
Because it's not mine.
因为它不是我的。
Oh.
哦。
To me, it's the public's. It's a public document. It should be put somewhere where everybody can see it.
对我来说，它是公众的。这是一份公共文件。它应该放在每个人都能看到的地方。
It's the kind of historical document that could, should, end up in a textbook, but it probably won't. It will probably stay in Major Lyness's closet.
这是那种可能、应该进入教科书的历史文件，但可能不会。它很可能会留在莱尼斯少校的壁橱里。
I reached out to the CIA for comment on this story, for comment on Majid's treatment. In response, a CIA spokesperson sent me a statement-- quote, "The CIA's detention and interrogation program ended in 2009. The CIA has committed and remains committed to never again operating such a program of enhanced interrogation techniques," end quote.
我就这个故事、马吉德的待遇向中情局寻求评论。作为回应，中情局发言人发给我一份声明——引用，“中情局的拘留和审讯计划于2009年结束。中情局致力于且仍致力于永不再运行这种强化审讯技术的计划，”结束引用。
So many of the players in this story, in all these Guantánamo stories, just want to put that place behind them. The American government certainly wants us to forget about Gitmo, the black sites, the torture.
在这个故事中，所有这些关塔那摩故事中的许多参与者，只是想把那个地方抛在身后。美国政府肯定希望我们忘记关塔那摩、黑狱、酷刑。
And Majid, too. He finally got out of prison in February 2023, 11 months after his sentence officially ended.
马吉德也是。他在2023年2月终于出狱了，在他刑期正式结束11个月后。
His attorneys met him in Belize, helped him set up his new house. Two months later, Rabia and Manaal joined him. He helped Manaal hang rainbow-colored lights around her room. He spotted her as she put a ladder on a chair on her bed to reach the ceiling. In some photos he and Rabia took shortly after they were reunited, they're both beaming, like newlyweds.
他的律师在伯利兹见了他，帮他布置了新家。两个月后，拉比亚和曼娜尔加入了他的行列。他帮曼娜尔在房间里挂上彩虹色的灯。当她把梯子放在椅子上再放在床上以够到天花板时，他护着她。在他们团聚后不久他和拉比亚拍的一些照片中，他们都笑逐颜开，就像新婚夫妇。
Majid spent the first 20 years of adult life in prison. Now, suddenly, at the age of 44, he's a husband and a father. He has a 20-year-old daughter and a new baby. He's got to learn to raise a kid, find a job, convince the banks to give him a bank account.
马吉德在监狱里度过了成年生活的前20年。现在，突然间，44岁的他成了丈夫和父亲。他有一个20岁的女儿和一个刚出生的孩子。他得学习抚养孩子，找份工作，说服银行给他开个账户。
He doesn't want to be talking about any of this stuff, doesn't want to relive it. He couldn't sleep the week I was in Belize interviewing him. He just wants to move on.
他不想再谈论任何这些事情，不想重温它。我采访他的那周他在伯利兹几乎睡不着觉。他只是想向前看。
I don't give a fuck about history. Like, I don't want it to be a part of history-- with all due respect, I just want to be forgotten. You know, who cares? Who's Majid Khan? If I die and bury someone someplace, I will make sure nobody knows where I am. When I die, I just want to make sure only two people come-- my two loved ones. That's it, my daughter and my wife. I'm happy. That's what I prefer.
我根本不在乎历史。就像，我不希望它成为历史的一部分——恕我直言，我只想被遗忘。你知道，谁在乎？马吉德·汗是谁？如果我死了把某人埋在某处，我会确保没人知道我在哪儿。我死的时候，我只想确保只有两个人来——我的两个至爱。就这样，我的女儿和妻子。我很幸福。那是我更喜欢的。
Majid told me the sentencing hearing, the clemency letter, they were validating in the moment, but writ large, the American public? He doesn't think anyone noticed. And he's probably right.
马吉德告诉我判决听证会、减刑信，它们在当时是有效的，但大范围来看，美国公众？他不认为有人注意到。他可能是对的。
But you know who did notice? The accused masterminds of 9/11-- or their lawyers, anyway. If Majid got a more lenient sentence because he was tortured, could they? Next time.
但你知道谁注意到了吗？9/11事件的策划者们——或者至少是他们的律师。如果马吉德因为被折磨而获得了更宽大的判决，他们能吗？下一次。
That'll be next time on Serial and on our show as well. We'll be running one more episode from the Guantánamo series next week.
那将是下一次《Serial》和我们的节目。我们下周将播放关塔那摩系列的最后一集。
[BECK, "MODERN GUILT"]
Season 4 of Serial was edited by Julie Snyder, with additional editing from Jen Guerra and myself. It's produced by Serial and The New York Times.
《Serial》第四季由朱莉·斯奈德编辑，詹·格拉和我本人进行了额外编辑。它由Serial和《纽约时报》制作。
You can hear the rest of the season-- and I recommend it-- all about Guantánamo wherever you get your podcasts. Other people who have put this season together include Rozina Ali, Cora Currier, Sofia Degli Alessandri, Emma Grillo, Mack Miller, Ben Phelan, Carol Rosenberg, Al-Amyn Sumar, Ndeye Thioubou, Phoebe Wang, Susan Wessling, and New York Times deputy managing editor Sam Dolnick.
您可以在任何获取播客的地方听到这一季的其余部分——我推荐它——全关于关塔那摩。参与本季制作的其他人员包括Rozina Ali、Cora Currier、Sofia Degli Alessandri、Emma Grillo、Mack Miller、Ben Phelan、Carol Rosenberg、Al-Amyn Sumar、Ndeye Thioubou、Phoebe Wang、Susan Wessling以及《纽约时报》副主编Sam Dolnick。
Sean Cole, Mike Comite, Sarah Koenig, Safiyah Riddle, Matt Tierney, and Jessica Weisberg did the work to put this Serial episode onto our program. Special thanks today to Talia Baiocchi, Alison Beckman at the Center for the Victims of Torture, Nina Lassam, Alvin Melathe, and Tug Wilson.
肖恩·科尔、迈克·科米特、萨拉·凯尼格、萨菲亚·里德尔、马特·蒂尔尼和杰西卡·魏斯伯格完成了将这一集《Serial》放入我们节目的工作。今天特别感谢Talia Baiocchi、酷刑受害者中心的Alison Beckman、Nina Lassam、Alvin Melathe和Tug Wilson。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以免费流媒体收听我们超过800集的存档。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He does not understand why people at the office did not get his Halloween costume last year. He's like, isn't it obvious? A rhinoceros on St. Patrick's Day.
一如既往，感谢我们项目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他不明白为什么办公室的人去年没看懂他的万圣节服装。他说，这不是很明显吗？圣帕特里克节的犀牛。
I was a greenhorn.
我当时是个雏儿。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[BECK, "MODERN GUILT"]
Next week on the podcast of This American Life. Most of the people imprisoned at Guantánamo were low-level fighters at best. More than 95% were never charged with a crime. But if there was any case at Guantánamo where you think justice would be done, it was the trial for the man accused of orchestrating 9/11.
下周在《美国生活》的播客中。关塔那摩关押的大多数人充其量是低级别的战士。超过95%的人从未被指控犯罪。但如果关塔那摩有任何案件让你觉得会伸张正义，那就是对那名被指控策划9/11事件的人的审判。
So, more than two decades later, how's it going with that trial? Answer-- even that's messed up in some really shocking ways. Next week on the podcast on your local public radio station.
那么，二十多年过去了，那场审判进行得如何？答案——即使是那样也以一些非常令人震惊的方式搞砸了。下周在您当地公共广播电台的播客上。